all right hello everyone we are
continuing our design review
investigation
about multi-computation
and
we've been talking about let's take a
look here we're looking at trace graph
and causal graph okay so trace graph
so this is an attempt to represent
a computational process evaluating in
this case
the
fourth fibonacci number is that right
yep
okay
so let's see what actually happens here
so
you say
it's always very dangerous to define an
f here
uh this is
the result from trace why is trace graph
still blue here
i didn't provide any code yet because
there's still some pretty serious bugs
in it
okay but let's take a look at what this
picture is actually showing
so f of 4
is
structurally f
for
well i don't really understand that but
yeah okay and then this red means an
evaluation event is that right
yep
so the f and the four both evaluated to
themselves
okay
and then the f of four
i mean why aren't you doing this in
terms of events because this really
makes it kind of hard to see what's
going on
i mean
this is really
this dotted line is an event is that
true
is that right that's an evaluation what
do you mean by event
well what we've always been talking i
spelled out
so we have two kinds of nodes and four
kinds of edges
and i spelled out what they are above
okay okay fine
okay the nodes
non-highlighted nodes are expressions
whose parts need to be evaluated
highlighted nodes
these parts do not need to evaluate it
because they already were evaluated
either because they were already
evaluated or because
the head has non-standard evaluation
well but what about the four here that
that doesn't need to be evaluated
um
right so in the output of trace
this is just represented as a singleton
list
and so i split it up into two different
nodes
so that you have the
non-highlighted node
is from the just expression
decomposition
and the highlighted nodes come from
things that have evaluated
okay non-highlighted solid edges
go from an expression to an unevaluated
expression for a subsidiary expression
okay so that's these kinds of edges here
that's a drill down so in order to
evaluate f of 4 you need to evaluate f
and you need to evaluate
right but you are still retaining the
memory that having done that these
reassemble in this way
that reassembly information which we
also had in these um
um
weird kinds of events in combinators
that that reassembly event i mean maybe
nick has a comment on this
um
uh
i don't understand reassembly events
okay
because they're different from other
things we've looked at
okay right so you only get the solid
highlighted edges whenever you have
started with
the solid non-highlighted edges
so only if you have subsidiary
evaluations do you then have to
reassemble reassemble yeah
right does anybody have a comment nick
or anybody else have a comment about the
reassembly process
i think it's important because it's then
when you can apply it down values or
values etc i know but that's something
we haven't seen we saw it in combinators
we haven't seen it elsewhere
i have it in the token and graph this
notion of
recombination
i have a two notion special functions
decomposition and recombination
that's how you make tokens out of states
so you have an initial state then you
have an you have to decompose it into
tokens then you apply your events your
usual type of events that act on tokens
then the resulting tokens are getting
recombined into
into our next state or several states
again
and do do transformations get applied to
states or only to tokens
trans rules are applied tokens
go to a set of tokens
but but jose just made the comment
that
you are reassembling to a state
in order to be able to apply down values
right so down values up values sub
values and up values are all
non-highlighted dashed edges
so out of the four kinds of edges the
non-highlighted dashed ones are the only
ones that are transformation rules
which in our other world will be
indicated with a yellow event
edge
you know it would it would have a dot
representing the event
so the only actual event that takes
place is this one here is that correct
everything else is a decomposition
or recomposition is that true
okay so
fallen edges are decomposition
recombination
the non-highlighted dashed edges or
transformation rules
the highlighted dashed edges are
a what
just kind of weird
no no that's not an answer what are they
they they they go from an atomic
expression that hasn't evaluated to that
same atomic expression after it's been
evaluated
why aren't they the same as the other
daughter weights to itself because if
they were own values then you wouldn't
get that kind of an edge
so it's something that only happens when
you have a value right if there were own
values
it would end up with something that does
this kind of thing where you go from f
of three to the cipher three you know
this thing here yeah exactly you'd have
you'd have a
a non-highlighted dashed edge directly
from the symbol to its value
right
so this is the case where the symbol
evaluates to itself
okay
all right so here
and and chris suggested last meeting um
maybe having an option to just combine
those nodes into one node and get rid of
those edges
these edges here yeah
okay
but the key point is the red things are
all recombination events
recombination processors
so essentially what's happening is
you take it apart
okay
so the issue is when things were taken
apart
as they have been here for example
we take it apart to f of three minus one
blah blah blah
that is then the reassembly okay so so
essentially what's happening is
in terms of these graphs
if the whole expression if nothing
evaluated in the whole expression you
would see the tree of the expression
followed by the reverse tree of the
expression
reconstructing the original expression
again is that correct
you would see a tree and an inverse tree
glued together
and so what's happening in in reality is
that
uh
the inverse tree
never has transformations happening in
it it is merely a reassembly
a true statement
well you can have transformations
in between the point when you
deconstruct and reassemble
absolutely absolutely but once you're in
the reassembly process
i mean
the reassembly is always just a one-step
thing like basically it's not even an
inverse tree it's it's always just these
two levels
it's just the parts and then one level
down to the new expression
you won't get arbitrary red trees
but you are getting arbitrary green
trees here right
i don't quite understand that statement
because so the red the red ones are
strictly just the last step once once
all of the parts have evaluated
no but you've got to reassemble look
look if we ran the same computation but
without
well i guess on some expression
some deeply nested expression that
doesn't evaluate
we will see a bunch of breaking down
tree pieces
and then reassembly tree pieces and
they'll be somehow symmetrical won't
they
yes but
each reassembly piece is always going to
be
one level
like this well in the same sense that
each disassembly piece is also only one
level at a time
right if you've got four levels down
you disassemble four levels well in the
sense that you know disassemble you can
disassemble and then immediately
disassemble again
you can't assembly is just
once and done
there won't be any further assembly
i don't understand that every level is
once and done but the same is true of of
disassembly go ahead
i think ian is just saying that here you
have for example four consecutive green
levels and then two red levels
so he's saying that you can have any
number of green levels consecutive
but it's always too red level but it
isn't it isn't it isn't because because
you have to reassemble the whole
expression yeah
if i had a deeply nested expression i
would go down level you reassemble the
parts of an expression
yeah the only thing that it's not a it's
not a nested
operation
it's strictly a level one thing you have
an expression you evaluate its parts
you assemble its parts
okay but don't you assemble having
assembled its parts you then go and
assemble
the things that came back from those
parts just like you're doing here
or am i confused in other words a deeply
nested expression once you've evaluated
the parts you're just going to have a
sequence of parts
and then you'll assemble them into an
expression you won't be assembling parts
get an expression assemble some more
parts get another expression a symbol
some no
you evaluate all the parts of the
expression and then you make a new
expression out of okay but on the way
down
you're doing that it's f of g of h and
so on
you're you've got an f level of g level
and h level
right or the deconstruction steps for
the deacon for the deconstruction step
yes
but are you saying that the
reconstruction step is is only one step
at all the deconstruction step is
recursive the reconstruction step is
just a single step
that takes place after all
pick on somebody christopher do you
understand this
not really
the reconstruction step happens after
all recursion has finished
so it's it is itself not a recursive
thing but why doesn't it have to come up
one level at a time reconstructing one
because that's the reconstruction step
from the previous level
but that happens after the
reconstruction step from level two after
the reconstruction step from level two
is finished then you get the
reconstruction step from level one don't
you
put what we're seeing here you know the
ones that are higher up on the page or
reconstruction steps from earlier
exactly exactly but my point is if there
was no evaluation or reconstruction step
is just one step of course
of course just like the actual
deconstruction step here is only one
step for three minus one it's only one
step but for a depth two expression it's
it's two levels two steps
right and and the reconstruction here
again
is two steps there's this one and then
there's this one but we have something
more going on because we have an
evaluation yeah
i think we have to see your trace graph
things they're just they're just
independent things i think
i think there's a symmetry between them
do you think there is
between them the symmetry is if you
introduce a deconstruction step
then
later you have to have a reconstruction
step exactly exactly
so for every deconstruction layer level
there's a reconstruction and my
statement is
you can follow a deconstruction step
immediately with another deconstruction
step
yes follow a reconstruction step with a
transformation rule
okay that's not obvious to me that
you're not following the reconstruction
step with another reconstruction step
right look like look anywhere where you
have i know i can see because you've got
evaluation going on here right i
understand that i'm saying if you had an
expression that didn't have evaluation i
think you get a series of deconstruction
steps followed by the reverse series of
reconstruction steps am i wrong
i mean that sounds correct but it will
still be the case that all of the red
highlighted parts will just be two
levels
yes i know i know each individual look
look they're gonna be exactly like this
they're going to be the mirror image of
this
are you saying the green is just two
levels no each individual green step
is two levels
right but they but they yeah and
i'm not making a statement about
individual levels i'm talking i'm making
a statement about what you can follow a
level with
okay but you can follow a reconstruction
level slowing down green levels
what but you do not keep you there's no
continually reconstructing things you
reconstruct things and then you apply a
trait i don't understand if there wasn't
evaluation this would go straight okay
if this didn't have evaluation right it
would go straight back up
the three minus one would get an f
wrapped around it and then it would get
the plus wrapped around it wouldn't it
just going straight from red levels to
red levels
surely that's correct
it recurses down it checks things out
it is essentially tokenizing it is it is
breaking things apart into tokens it's
saying for any one of these tokens is
there a transformation rule if yes
then we're jumping out in some other
direction
if no it's just going deconstruct
reconstruct i think
isn't it
i'm pretty sure that's right i mean
we'll know for sure if you make a trace
graph on something that doesn't evaluate
anybody else want to comment on this
i think it just has to be this way
go ahead yes i i think you're right and
and certainly we need many more examples
and with hell withhold attributes and
things like that
right but we need examples where it just
doesn't evaluate at all where all it is
is you know sniffing its way down into
the burrows so to speak and then coming
back up again
um
now and what we also don't have here is
we have no
uh
for this
we can already see that there's space
like separated events
okay this event and this event are space
like separated
are they not
they could happen in any order doesn't
matter
um
assuming no side effects space there are
no side effects here there are no side
effects space like separation means
in this case that they come from
different branches of a deconstruction
step
that's correct
right and what we're going to see
remember
right
okay
that's space-like separation we're also
going to see um
uh
you know we're also going to see um
um
kind of uh
um
what am i saying we're also going to see
um
um
branch-like separation
um
uh
when we have multiple possible
transformations that can happen
which you do not have here
am i making sense
okay let's go on okay this is very
helpful we're getting that now how close
are you to having actual code that just
does this in all cases
i think pretty close i just need time to
work on it what i have works for down
values i hear that that's enough that's
really enough we don't don't don't try
and do every other possible kind of
value and holds all the other values are
crashing the front end so okay well
whatever it doesn't make any difference
i don't care we've got tons to study
just with what you have here if it does
down values
make sense does it do down code as well
yes it does because we've got one here
right
that's absolutely enough please do not
go on and work on other stuff with this
until we've had a chance to really play
with us so so could i run the code that
you have now
yeah okay great wonderful
okay
visually this isn't quite right
because we're gonna need we maybe nick
is about to show us something that has
more event oriented because this is the
main event is that transformation right
there
yep
yeah right it's just below
the version of this event is explicit
okay
okay
okay
wait so this is showing a causal graph
of that event
i'm now totally confused by this now
what does this mean
well this is just the those events from
there this is this kind of graph derived
from the
that graph above
maybe the older version where the events
are exactly those dashed edges
okay evaluation edges
okay and this is showing the causal
interdependence of those evaluation
edges
right
so
it's a little bit confusingly upside
down for me
oh maybe it isn't i mean that event has
happened
in what sense does that event cause the
three minus one goes to two event
well because three minus one is that
appears there right
yeah you have to make this
to make this frame p minus one
i see i see ics yes
right that makes sense
but so
okay
so this is if we were to make the full
token event graph maybe that's what
you're about to do here but we see both
the tokens and the events
wow
what's this
okay
yeah let's just move this out
so you're saying
okay f of three
by an event goes to this
right
now
in like a string rewriting system we're
not explicitly showing
the
burrowing into the string just as we're
here we're just saying
see what's really confusing here
oh i see
this is a state-based thing so every
is it the case in this picture
that every single uh state is equal to f
three
well they're tokens yes the the tokens
tokens are
all
for a single state though
right now
yeah yeah so what you're saying is in
this picture
oh how interesting okay
so this is
sort of quantum mechanics or something
this is this is the state of the whole
universe
and this is saying these are equivalent
states of the universe
related by events
and what we're seeing here
so in the end f of three we're
interested in it going this is actually
a very nice picture but this looks like
it's all possible
of evaluations if you go up a little bit
it is it is it is all possible
evaluations okay
whereas
in
ian's graph
what's the relationship between these
two
so the one on the right is just
replacement rules
right like i i don't think that's
accurately always going to show what the
evaluator does
you need to write your replacement
something that gives a similar output as
trace
whereas trace graph i'm converting the
output of trace into a graph
version is a hack right now you have to
specify all the rules manually
you you don't extract it from the down
values
automatically okay but but
what you're saying is this is the
multi-way version
well this is a token event graph
which is by the nature of token event
graphs multi-way
correct
and
this is a single way evaluation correct
yeah
in the in the relationship section
there's a
there's a single wave version
extract it from the motorway
okay so there's the multi-wave version
yeah that's the pure causal graph
that's a much awkward graph yeah
this one here
yeah well
those two yeah right
and this is the single way
that corresponds to the one
path that evaluator takes
and it's it's the same causal graph
as above
there's something
okay
you mean you're saying this is the same
as ian's graph or what
well the same causal graph has
the one that extracted directly from the
ian's graph above so this causal graph
is the same as the one above which one
above the the one sorry the another one
here
yeah this one's the same cause
the causal graph portion of this
in which
that
event
is recorded as being that token goes to
that token is that correct
right oh it doesn't look right it
doesn't look right because this here
these events here are only showing
they're not showing the ambient stuff
around they're just showing two minus
two goes to zero they're not showing
where that appears in a complete state
well no yeah they're not showing it but
they
respond to the same thing
so there could be multiple identical
things here identical three minus one
goes to whatever could occur multiple
times but in different contexts is that
true
i don't think so like this is how
this would still show the same kind of
thing
i'm a little confused by that
but but so okay so what you're saying
here is
this is a single way graph that says the
evaluator goes f three goes to this goes
to this goes to this
so this is a particular path
you can also think of it like i'm doing
reconstruction
all the way back to the
like to the initial expression
while
the trace graph
that even shows
is just only shows the sub expression in
individual sub expression
if if you would follow the
reconstruction every time all the way
back
then that would be i super said
but again in your graphs every node is
the whole expression
yeah so
and
just like what we've done for strings
it is merely from that state there are
these events that can happen
but we're not well representing the
drill down into the string
to show where those events happen
which is what ian is doing in this so
yeah so i think the relationship is this
um
what nick's doing is
correct me if if i'm simplifying it but
it's a generalization of replace
repeated
like it's a list of rules and you're
applying those rules just verbatim to
expressions and applying them in all
possible ways
and the single wave version is like find
replace path
like i've got this collection of rules
go from here to here it's not replace
repeater it's replaced list repeated
somehow uh-huh yeah so the thing with
the evaluator is it's not
it's not like replace repeated it's it's
got a deterministic way of traversing
expressions and
um
rep and repeatedly applying things
during the traversal
and yeah i understand that is what
tracecraft is trying to represent with
all those extra edges is the traversal
that it's doing to find where to apply
transformation rules
i understand i understand completely i
think that that is directly analogous to
what happens with strings
okay so for example
if we look
at
just pick up a random example of this
um
okay if we look at this
actually what i really want
is uh what is it called events what is
it called
the thing that shows both the states and
the events
what is that called evolution events
graph is that right
okay
this here
is doing the same thing that what next
the the next thing is doing
in other words it is just saying
these are the possible transformations
from bbb
it's not giving us mechanistically how
to drill in to get to those things
do you get what i'm saying
yeah the two simplest cases for that
would just be traverse it from left to
right or from right to left whatever
whatever i mean there are many different
ways to do it and that there are many
different
ways to decide how many of these events
you can happen i mean sometimes these
events will overlap here they overlap
you can't do all three of those events
together
sometimes you can i mean there are and
also the evaluator is not a
multi-evaluator there's always a
definite rule that will be applied i
know i know i know so in the evaluator
probably this one here where the event
where the transformation happens at the
first place it can is what will get
applied
so okay but but what you're doing
is you are breaking apart this step here
right to say
how does it scan that expression and
determine that that is the first
transformation it can make
i think the scanning and the choice of
rule are
independent
or you know
you can make different choices for them
like two different rules could apply at
the same place or one
or two different places sure
absolutely
absolutely but the the the most people
want to be able to show both of those
processes
that's what the multi-weight graph is
going to do
it's going to show that's the branchial
direction i mean
what you've got here
i mean i'm a little confused can
somebody help unconfuse me i mean in
this case here
we're not and in the case that nick's
showing he's not bothering to show
the substructure of how does it get to
decide that bb goes to a in the first
element is the
correct evaluator path
whereas ian is showing us
some of the breakdown of how you test
these things
and
i mean
what you're doing
is a token decomposition or a state
decomposition function basically you're
saying break the state up according to
this tree as treeing
and at any stage in the sub tree
you can end up doing the transformation
if nothing is transformed then it goes
back into a reflected tree and gets
reconstructed again so essentially
you're breaking apart this event step
here
into something that has that you can
understand
by recursing through that tree
that makes sense
yes
okay
so and now you've sent some mail here
um
[Music]
make sure you save anything before you
try running this
oh
yeah i just want to make a logistical
point but roger are you aware of the
meeting about category three design
later on this afternoon did anybody
invite you to that
yes
okay good
all right
this is
this all right so what i want to do is i
just want to say okay trace
of f of g of x
oh for god's [ __ ] sake
why does that do nothing your trace
original goes to true
okay now i want to see that in your
graph
how do i do that do i just say trace
graph of of trace or trace graph of the
if trace race graph of the expression
with no options
magnificent
it just crashed completely
what's happening there
i
write the code in terms of pattern
matching on the output of trace and i
have missing patterns so get stuck in an
infinite recursion
and what blows up memory and then
crashes
it should recursion limit or something
though like i mean i think that's what i
would have expected i don't know why the
front end here
but why are you talking about the front
end what's the front end got to do with
it
no i have no idea why the front end is
crashing but i'm saying that my code is
definitely going into an infinite loop
there's some deeper bug that may be
worth
tracking down anyway
well it seems worthwhile to find out
what that pug is
okay
i'm very worthwhile it's a crash bug has
somebody wronged in the debugger
nope
well you need to do that i mean can you
do that do you know how to do that
yep
okay
how was this this is in
trace graph here
oh did i just delete it
was i down here
oh no i was where was i it was here
no i don't know where i was yep that's
where
okay
so do you think it works on any
all right let's see it has bad behavior
when things don't evaluate
using down values and down code
okay
so oneplus one
does that it reconstructs itself
it probes
kind of the sub
subterranean
things and then decides that there
really isn't anything interesting there
so if i were to do this
okay let's take a look at that for a
second
so it drills it drills drills
and
okay
okay so that's the evaluation step there
okay so i i think it really is true that
this is a substructure
of next graph
the next version can i see next version
of this how do i get that
of that same trace graph
i have a trace causal graph
function
in the codograph section i think there's
but don't i want this kind of thing
instead if i want to get that function
there
that i want to get that thing there what
do i do for one because you have to make
those rules
by hand
yeah
okay so this needs to be sorted out so
we don't have to do that by hand but i
mean so
um
because what do you think this graph
will look like in your
setup it'll have
three events if i'm not mistaken
yeah i think so
and
at every stage it'll be a complete state
here
i mean can we encode it in in what
you've got up here could we encode that
same
yeah i think it's you don't have to have
this f
you just
maybe modify a little bit this that plus
rule
wait a minute
remove everything else
okay so when we modify the plus rule we
want to say
a blank plus b blank
what do i want to do colon equals a plus
b
really
well
you don't you have to inactivate it
somehow
so it's it's almost the same rule you
just maybe
add times to it
or just use
process all together without types so
it's just the same rule
i'm sorry i'm i'm completely confused
the same rule is what
just from from the left
the one rule that involves plus
this one here
yeah
sorry where does that go let's see
you're mopping over
okay so we want this and then we want
the corresponding thing for times
you can just like add
alternatives and active plus
more times
now it has to go to the same thing on
the right hand side
might as well just do this
okay how do i feed in i say
inactivated
of this is that right
yeah
inactivate your expression
maybe add more parentheses
yeah
okay
that's nice
so that's a multi-way graph
so ian's analog of that is
let's put these side by side
okay
where do we see two times one plus one
in ian's thing
i don't think we do
am i right
correct because it never happens
what do you mean by happens
two never gets multiplied by
uh one plus one it gets multiplied by
two
but the i'm confused here the one the
other one plus one gets rewritten in the
two
that's yeah i don't understand i don't
understand why why wouldn't there be
okay you're saying in the evaluator as
the evaluator is this is what happens
it maximally rewrites these things
because they're non-overlapping and so
it gives us
uh always 2 times 2. is that correct
yes
but it certainly doesn't have to be that
way i mean if we were running this in
parallel on multiple processors
then next version would be the correct
representation of the different possible
paths where either this one can be
evaluated first or this one can be
evaluated it's a difference between
deconstructing and reconstructing or
just doing it in place
i know this has got complete
parallelization
okay we're fine but but how would we
represent the parallelization because
you've got the parallelization
represented because those two tokens
are independently updatable
right
so
again
okay is it the case
that uh
um
that i can puff out
this event
into something involving your
deconstruction reconstruction
is that true
i think you could have
like an evolution of this graph at each
node
in
the top graph
and you would see things
expanding out in place so like on that
left branch
you see the two
but the one plus one hasn't changed
so that would be like a stage in this
graph where you would have
blown out the one plus one right so it's
a foliation in which left
the other one would still just be right
but it's a foliation where you're going
like this and you go up
well there
above this
it's foliation in which this one has
been done and this one has not yet been
done
um
okay
okay let's let's make a road map for
what has to happen
so i think
well nick can you say okay first
question is
in next picture here
this particular example is confluent
is that a general fact about
um
is it the case that without side effects
it's always confluent
it should be yeah
okay
so this is telling us from roger's point
of view about parallel computing and so
on
this is telling us
within this graph
are all possible histories with
different pieces of
i'm doing at different time done
different times
what ian is going to be able to give us
is a more microscopic map
of how that parallelism happens or
doesn't happen with respect to
sub-expressions
am i am i correct
does that make sense ian can you speak
to that please
i mean
i think it's like parallelization in
time and rules
yeah well that's called space like
versus branch like separated
look the different
rules here
the
okay branch-like separation
let's see how where are the branch-like
separated things the
those two events there are space-like
separated is that correct
well we actually don't know they could
be overlapping
[Music]
nick or anybody else can you say what
the condition is
oh what
for um
uh branch-like versus space-like
separated events
there's a simple criterion that if two
events
merge at a previous state their space
like separated if they merged a previous
event that branch like separated i think
that's right
maybe the easier criteria is
when
the same rule may be the same rule acts
and different positions
or maybe it's a
different role same and
in the same position
yes
but the same rule you know rules acting
at different positions are space like
separated if they're not overlapping
yeah
which is to say that in a parallel
computation they could be done in any
order
right right
could this be a combinatorial problem
because if there are n objects
are we going to have like n factorial
and different lines here
yes if you can do them in any order yes
that's correct
and that's exactly why
that's the whole theory of global local
and global multi-way systems
because there is much redundancy
because we're looking at complete states
here
what you say is correct jose even though
those individual tokens there might be
10 individual tokens but there are 10
factorial ways of dealing with the whole
set of tokens that might be updated if
that makes sense
yes
i'm just thinking that from the
representation point of view it will be
a lot more complicated than having 10
parallel lines as in ian's graph
well i mean look there is a trade-off
guys it's the same thing in space time
there's a trade-off between
the
nodes of the multi-way graph are
complete states of the universe
in which case it's an incredibly
wasteful graph
because the complete state of the
universe is repeated many many many
times with just tiny changes
okay the alternative is
to keep track of the changes
but not say how they're assembled into
complete states that's the local
multi-way idea or the token event graph
idea usually
nick do you see how to merge what you're
doing with what ian is doing
what
what amount of immersion is required
well i would like to see a graph
that can where i can turn a knob from
going between global and local multi-way
systems
well what you have right now is
essentially a global multi-way system
well if you if if you talk about token
graph in general then it can be
there are some knobs there that
can go from local to global through
local
in any way you can
yes but we need to see that because
because what we're saying here is
we have a prototype
it's like
when i actually have explicit
recombination of expression
and merging them
into states
okay
nick
is this just the one with the states are
those mint green
vertices
yeah we've looked at those during
previous meetings yeah
no we have more than that it's like oh
you want to show something quickly you
can open the it's in the working
material physics working material
it's called expression tech
i have just one example there
it's a it's a mess right now but
it's in progress
i don't understand this picture at all
this is the
now it contains all those
types of
vertices right we have token states and
events
you start with the with start with the
state
it it
it can be decomposed into all
sub-expressions
right that that's what makes the state
then events actually yeah i draw it
like like events act on the stage but
they actually act on stock tokens
there's like more tokens that you can
add to this graph actually but
i'm not doing it right so so
and
ian's way of doing this this will be
broken into tokens and then events would
act on the tokens
yeah that's actually what it's doing
it's just i'm just not showing it like
that
right okay those are those events act on
tokens
okay
each one of these is probably
a single token being evaluated
yeah it depends on your rule but in
principle can be more than one
and then you collect all the outputs
from all your events
and you make more states and it can be
more than one
like in this example you can make two
expressions instead
and that's a different rule
there
all right i think we're progressing here
i mean
anybody else want to make comments
before we wrap up here
um
this reminds me very much of the
difference between cvs and git in cvs
you keep track of individuals changes in
individual files while in git you always
worry about the state of your whole file
system and you keep changes of the whole
file system
and you have also two different sets of
graphs
well that's interesting
so you're saying git is more like the
global multi-way system
exactly
okay
roger do you have any thoughts
well
um depends on what we wanted to
um end up with i mean one
possibility
is that there is a family of functions
that let you visualize
and understand evaluation and that may
be that's part of what we want yes click
click and expand out something or
contract something exactly yes that is
part of what we want as a debugger well
you might say how did the evaluation
happen
right in which case we probably need to
invent
more ways to compress things
yes or or focus in on areas
yep
yep that's a different thing so that's a
that's the thing where this graph
if you drilled it all the way down and
this graph has to be dynamically built
because you're not going to want to
build the whole graph for everything
all the time i think i think
i think another concept
that's the same i mean it's it's sort of
related but but you know working at a
certain level of abstraction so you
don't want to see event below a certain
level type things
yeah
right but okay so one definite thing is
the debugging process
the other thing is understanding
is
you know
the the real thing we're going for is
the general way of doing multi-way
computation because it's one thing to do
our particular evaluation sequence it's
another to look at the whole multi-way
graph and look at other evaluation
sequences
see what i'm saying so ultimately steven
what should an evaluation graph be able
to do like in a few weeks when it's
ready well i mean one thing it should do
is
be able to
uh i mean i need to go to a different
meeting here but but one thing that it
needs to do
is be able to oh wait a minute
i don't understand this hold on one
second i'm not confused
what happens here oh
okay
something got moved all right okay
fair enough we have a few more minutes
here then
um
okay then then let's review what we're
trying to do okay
okay remember evaluation is a single way
process
i understand i understand okay so
one side effect of this project is
good
graph visualization of the single
single-way process that is evaluation
thing number one
thing number two
is
understanding how we get multi-way
evaluation
which our evaluator does not do
right right
so multi-way evaluation i mean next
token event graphs are doing multi-way
evaluation
we would like to get as general a
multi-way evaluator as possible that is
we want a multi-way evaluator such that
we type in an expression in our language
which would normally undergo single-way
evaluation
okay but we want a multi-way evaluator
for that
and in the past it's like what's the
point of this
because if there aren't side effects
it's going to give the same answer
whichever of those multi-weight bars you
take
if you get it all the way to the end if
you get the fixed point
all the way to the end it's well maybe
it isn't i don't know i don't even know
no that isn't even true sorry i i re i i
take that back it isn't true that you'll
always get the same answer
but we've always been interested in the
particular answer that you get from the
single way evaluator path
i understand all that i mean i
understand the second thing we want i'm
just clarifying for everybody else the
the the second thing we want
is to be able to type in an arbitrary
wolfram language expression
and see its multi-way
evaluation graph
all right so one question there is
as nick mentioned before with fibonacci
so he can represent it as a tag
and he could probably even represent it
with this nice
um
you know glocal global local graph he
has now but he still had to enter the
rules manually well that's hopeless
that's absolutely hopeless yeah yeah
hold on right that's not what we want
yeah
not done right okay so ultimately for a
general
evaluation graph
it can't be the case that you enter it
manually you want to just be able to
enter any arbitrary expression in the
language
yes and automatically you get the
evaluation graph yes
so nick and i have discussed this nick
he has some concerns about next steps
for doing that so let's address those
now
i think
nick
well
well my concerns are that it's
it can be a mess i don't know
it's like
what happens with all those
language constructs
how do you then make them into a rules
how how do you make a general multi-role
out of any proof of language
construction
okay
let's restrict ourselves okay so
currently
down code is single way all down code is
single way
am i making sense it does it has a
definite answer you feed an input it
gives an answer
right
i think that the answer is that the
things that are represented as rules
like steven is going down so there are
all these rules right down um the values
yeah but there are also code that isn't
rules
there's like you can't progress any
further
it's basically stops there
well no no i'm saying that a pattern
matcher
is easy to generalize to multi-way
yes
so the things that are rules
yeah they're easy to generalize now
other things like
i don't know some polynomial operation
well like for example the plus operation
there is an obvious multi-way
generalization of plus that involves you
know for symbolic xyz the multi-way
version of that presumably has x y and z
in all orders
and all parenthesizations presumably i
don't know i haven't thought about it
this is
in a in a very different world
this would be like some kind of
quantization of a classical
phenomenon
uh
you know it is
multi-way fine things
and as i say some things are very easy
to multi-way if i
for example
the so
our rules are easy
our functions
which evaluate their arguments are also
quite easy
if we make the assumption which may or
may not be true that we can evaluate the
arguments in any order
but probably is true
for functions that evaluate their
arguments that probably is true you can
just evaluate in any order
i'm making sense
so
right
so it would be enough to understand
what's going on if all we did here
was we started off by saying let's
multi-wayify things defined by pattern
matching rules
am i making sense because there's an
obvious generalization right there are
pattern matching rules that are
underdetermined where there are multiple
matches that could happen yes
it'll be x triple blank you know y blank
z triple bank that has many possible
matches
and then what i would like to see is
some standard problems that people do
with logic programming for example or
with the np type problems done this way
see what i'm saying
yes no maybe makes sense
i think the problem is
it's not the
it's like the way you multiverify
this kind of
rules it's not by the rooms yourself but
the position when you can apply it
so if you're given a down value there
are multiple place where you can apply
it i think in general it's hard to
see maybe there's some scoping issues
like this rule can be applied here but
not there
even though it applies there by pattern
matching
like if it's inside of module or
something like that
yeah i understand i understand i
understand the full multiverification of
our whole language is quite complicated
right we're not close to that it's a big
language it's got lots of scoping
constructs it's got lots of generated
variables all kinds of things like this
we are not dealing with that yet
okay we may want to deal with generated
variables fairly soon or at least simple
cases of that fairly soon because that
may be a big piece of the story
okay because clearly
two modules
that
are being run in different branches will
generate different explicit names for
their variables
although they will canonicalize to the
same name
they are nominally different names on
different branches
does that make sense
i mean that's what we've seen a whole
bunch of times
right
nick you've written all kinds of code
that does this yes
oh yeah but what you do with if you have
a module you you have to
use a down value for module
it's like how you unwrap it
is it
kind of a rule that you wanna i know i
know
i keep on saying okay
our system is not a multi-way system it
is a single-way system that's what you
know we have a giant code base of many
tens of millions of lines of code or
whatever it is that is a single way
system
right
what we are doing here is we're doing
the investigation of slowly trying to
make pieces of it multi-way
and the first piece to make multi-way is
the pattern matcher
what we will do is steadily
in different pieces of the system
we can see how to make them multi-way
but how we make module multi-way i don't
know offhand
does that make sense
i i think so that would correspond to
having multiple dashed edges
the non-highlighted yes that's right
that's right that's correct you'd have
the potential for multiple different
ones like the down value or an up value
or a sub value
no no it's nothing to do with no no it's
not all those different it doesn't
matter about those different ones well
okay
there may be more than one definition
that could apply to it exactly in the
down values there could be 17
definitions that all apply and they lead
to different results yep that's the
multi-verification and the other
multi-way ification is the solid
non-highlighted edges
um like nick has on the left where you
have every single sub-expression
the evaluator only looks at
the parts at level one
uh
sorry says it again
so like trace graph has
three edges out of there for the times
and the one plus one and the one plus
one
if you multi-way if i that that would be
you'd have edges not just for those
three sub-expressions but for every
sub-expression
yes i think so
look
the full multi-way graph is going to be
very big
okay we've said this a thousand times
right it's going to be very big
and worse than that
it may not even have a fixed point
okay
but then what we are trying to do is
we're trying to ask for different types
of evaluation
where it is not
following a single way path to a fixed
point which is what we've been doing for
the last 35 years
or more
okay we're asking for for example look
at all the possible paths
and ask the one that for example gives
the smallest number in this place
or something
right different types of observers of
the multi-way computation
do you get what i'm saying
okay and let's just review again
why we want that why do we care
right can somebody okay we care because
many styles of computation
use something other than the input
single way evaluation output model
okay for example logic programming
uses
you know is there a path that gets from
here to there np problems
is there a way to get to this thing that
satisfies this constraint
you know hash p problems how many things
are there that gets that satisfy this
constraint
you know etc
does that make sense or probabilistic
programming what's the probability you
know what are the different outcomes
with what probabilities
maybe somebody else has another example
anybody else have another example
roger
jose tony christopher anybody
i was thinking of past integral type
things
yes i think that's very obvious yeah
which is more like part but
probabilistic programming
but it's probabilistic programming with
a
a phase for every path
yes but
somehow they interact right they
yes that's what happens in these
multi-way graphs that's the whole point
is that there's branching and there's
merging
i mean the the the path integral case
requires that kind of model of quantum
mechanics
in which the bronchial position is the
phase
so moving around in branchial space
is what corresponds to a change in phase
um
well okay i think we're probably sounds
like everybody has gone silent here so
we're probably um
uh
um
anything else that anybody wants to add
here well just just to review so i mean
in terms of what we'll be working on for
next week nick
this
next step of generalizing
pattern matching
multi-computationally
do you have any other concerns about
that or do you think that that sounds
it seems that's what
have basically implemented with
multi-replace i just want to make sure
like while we're still on the call
before we depart
oh yeah
i don't know what what else should i do
it's like multiplies here that's right
you can
use any rule and just search for
different positions even if i have a
down value rules
sure you can i can use those
right but i mean i think it's sufficient
i think we need a function that just
takes a bag of rules not as down values
just a bag of rules
and
you know
slash slash dot
will do the single way evaluation with
that bag of rules
am i making sense
yeah
and then what we want is the thing that
makes the multi-way evaluation with the
bag of rules
and by the way that bag of rules may not
even terminate
i don't think it's a bag i think it's
like an ordered bag
it's not ordered when it's multi-way no
it's multi-way all possibilities right
then it is a bag
right
but i agree with you in the evaluator it
is not a bag it is an ordered list
but how far away are we from already
having that
we're not very far
we just need it all cleaned up and and
then we need
okay the other thing that nick has done
is to look at rules with patterns on
both the left and right hand sides
sure
and
that's a new and different thing
which may be needed
it is needed to represent theorem
proving
equational theorem proving yeah okay
okay so that's another piece that is not
that is not the pure replaceless story
right and so what we should be able to
get
from this
is
something which is maybe not efficient
at first
but is a theorem proving result that is
we've got the multi-way computation
that's the entailment cone in our other
language
and
we've also got the theorem proving i can
find a path type result right
okay so let's see that all explicitly
with bags of rules
rules that are you know patterns on the
left hand side going to literals on the
right hand side and patterns to patterns
now what we also discussed in a previous
meeting was utilities for patterns to
patterns rules
in fact in general utilities for
handling patterns
like we don't even have canonicalization
for patterns
as a built-in thing we need a family of
functions for handling patterns
that make sense
nick does that make sense
yeah
i mean you've already got one of those
functions so we just need to package
them up
okay
okay so now
um
all right so for next time i think what
we need to have
is bag of rules
and it will be useful if ian's
if if there can be a merger between
ian's stuff and nick's stuff
and
essentially what's happening is that
slash dot replace all
is drilling
through
uh
you know
that's the kind of
the borrowing operation of the evaluator
which we don't need down values for
we just can do that with rules and slash
dot am i correct
no we need a different kind of replace
repeated for it to mimic the evaluator i
think
i think replace repeated
like yes i agree it does not have the
exact same evaluation
yes yes that is correct slash dot does
not have the same evaluation order as
the evaluator you are right
but i i agree with you that there is a
sensible thing of give me a list of
rules and then traverse the expression
in a bottom-up depth first traversal
and don't progress back up the
expression until you reached a fixed
point at lower levels
is that what the evaluator does
yes
okay and then after it does that it does
the whole thing again
okay but so what you've got then is the
traversal order that corresponds to the
evaluator
but in the multi-way graph you have all
traversal orders
and you can define in essentially a tree
traversal order
you know with that same language for
tree traversal orders you can define one
traversal order which is the evaluator
it's it's traversal order plus the fact
that it's an infinite evaluator
okay fine
fine well we need to understand all of
this right we need to be able to
parametrize that so this is what our
evaluator does this is an alternative
evaluation order
and again i'm reminding you again
the whole point is to be able to get
things like logic programming where it
is not a particular evaluation order it
is all possible evaluation orders or
possible evaluation paths picking out
the path that satisfies a certain
constraint
yep right and we need a clean way to do
that and what i think we're going to
find is a family of functions that do
these different operations that are
standard for this different model of
evaluation
okay now meanwhile quite separately
roger is interested in what can be
parallelized i think
that a fair characterization
and yeah
how we run these things actually in
parallel on multiple threads
yes
but also
i mean
i'm a pragmatic guy i want actually sort
of usable tools
so
even if we can have
language constructs that says you know
make this you know
um
uh what's semicolon what's that a
compound statement
yeah compound expression like
you know you could have something that's
that's that's like parallel compound
expression says independent
yeah that's what we're calling multi a
few weeks ago right
you know so even markups like that that
makes the task easier to sort of you
know require less analysis
for instance if the analysis is not
always going to be possible
and so we we
we want to be able to i mean automation
is great
but even markup like openmp is kind of
markup and our coarse grain parallelism
is markup like parallel table and stuff
but we need
finer grained stuff yes and i mean
separately there's a separate project of
looking at the multi-threaded evaluator
as a practical
you know actually launching threads
yes
um
but the the thing that i'm looking for
with all of this stuff
they're two endpoints as far as i'm
concerned
you know
when you think about computations
there's a certain way we think about
them but one of the things we don't do
is what prologue used to do and what
uh
we do with constraint systems of various
kinds just say here are some constraints
find me something that satisfies these
it's kind of the generalization of
expression of equation solving
that's what i want us to be able to do
it's a style of programming that i think
will be useful
and obviously it has the issue that
prologue had if you never know how long
it's going to take in things
and that's part of the reason why
i think that these graph type things are
super useful because
they give one a lot more information
about what's really going on
you know as opposed to the problem that
people had with these kinds of uh you
know programming models before which is
just you you you know it becomes a black
art
of whether the thing will ever terminate
or not or will terminate in reasonable
time because you had no diagnostics
really
pretty much no diagnostics now similarly
with theorem provers
you know you've again got this thing
about i don't really know whether it's
ever going to find the path
and they're very few diagnostics
but i think
i mean with this what we will be able to
find
is theorem proving plus in addition to
the path it finds we'll be able to find
these kind of the
the tentacles hanging out
towards nearby paths and that will
probably be quite useful
so it's kind of it's enabling the style
of programming basically
and trying to make a nice formalism
for
what will ultimately be things that can
be done
as space-like separated computations
that is computations which
can be done at the same time in
different places so to speak
does that make sense
oh yeah
yeah
okay we should wrap here
but i'm excited about you know the real
progress is being made now i don't
completely know i mean i know ian has
other things to work on and i think
um it's possible that that nick should
take over the main heavy lifting here
um
uh
if i you know i don't really quite
understand what i mean nick has
i mean sorry ian has clarified a bunch
of what's involved in this kind of um
you know burrowing into expressions and
so on which is very useful
and i i don't quite know whether that
should be a you know do we need two
different code paths here or not
i think there is a smaller project here
which is helping with the output of
trace
which is which was the original
motivation for what ian is doing and
that might be
a nice project on itself and in fact
trace is
the trace of our sequential evaluator
i'm wondering what is trace for a
parallel
parallel evaluator
for a parallel single wave evaluator
trace will look very similar it'll just
have some space like separated pieces
this this thing we're seeing on the
screen here on the right
is basically a parallel trace
just happens to have been evaluated
sequentially
with depth first with some kind of depth
first traversal
it's gonna look the same i think
the the issue is when you draw it
foliated if this is a time foliation
this picture that we're seeing right
here is parallel
[Music]
the sequentialized version of this as
ian was just saying is the depth first
traversal of this thing
is that correct ian
the standard evaluator is that is a
depth first traversal of the expression
is it what i meant i
i don't know what a depth first reversal
of this graph would necessarily be well
because what's going to happen is
this piece here is going to evaluate
before this piece here
right maybe it isn't quite depth first
but there's an ordering this graph is
drawn in layers
where that layer there is a parallel
layer it's got this and this at the same
level so if this is time going down here
this is a parallel computation
i see see what i'm saying the
sequentialized version of this
would you know it would probably extend
this this i think that right branch
would just be shifted down
yes i agree i agree that's correct i
think that's right i think that that's
that is what you would see
in a and it's perhaps worth even having
that that kind of picture available
the the the actual order in which things
are done reading from top to bottom and
by the way these things here would no
longer be across the page they would be
that one and that one is lower on the
page that one is lower on the page and
so on
so their vertical coordinate
records the time at which they're done
but an example of a of a very tricky
phenomena which i don't know if we're on
path to capturing in parallel
is
is when they are not space-like
separated and they actually depend on
synchronizing in the right order exactly
that's branching separation you know
exactly branch like those bugs finding
those bugs i know but that's exactly
branch-like separation that's the point
branch-like separation is when there are
multiple branches you could go
and the question of whether so for
example when there is confluence
it doesn't matter which branch you took
right when there isn't confluence it
does matter and what can happen is there
can be locally non-confluent things
where if you say what happened at this
moment you say oh my gosh this piece ran
that one didn't i'm going to get a
different answer but it turns out it
doesn't matter in the end there's
eventual consistency
are there two kinds of confluence like
you could do
the same thing two different ways or you
need to do things on two different
branches just to get the next step
um
there isn't
the concept like a causal relationship
on two different parents instead of
saying a causal relationship on one
parent but you could have chosen
a different parent no i think that what
happens is
if you have a single time slice
um okay
a single way projection
squashes out the branchial direction
and makes a causal graph that is purely
space-time
if that's useful so in other words if
you say i've got a sequential computer
i've got i've got a non-quantum computer
so to speak what happens
you have to squash the branchial
direction you only get one path you only
get one set of things can happen
whereas with the brass shield direction
included you have multiple possible
things that can happen
which a which an ordinary computer
a theoretical quantum computer not the
actual ones because they have different
issues but a theoretical one could be
doing all those branchial all those
things on different branches
if that makes sense
um
was that an answer to what you were
asking or not i think i was
asking a slightly different question
which is
like
i think you're asking the difference
you're worried about branching was like
you could have gone this way or this way
but what about the case where you want
to go both ways and you need information
from both directions in order to get to
the next step okay it's different than
just that is not classical computation
that's not classical computation that's
the case where that reminds me of graphs
and find equational proof though
yes find equational proof is a branchial
story
it's not it's not somehow like the
different branches are different
branches it could have taken it's it
took all of those branches and it needed
them all to combine them together to get
a proof uh no no that that well okay
you're getting
that is the critical pair lemma story
yeah
okay the critical pair lemma story is an
optimization it is not necessary
this is hopefully explicated somewhere
in that 250-page
uh
um
meta-mathematics post that i just put
out
this this the the section on um
uh relationship to automated
automatically improving i believe
untangles this issue
that is
yeah i mean i but that's a good issue
right that's a good issue and critical
pair lemmas are precisely this
you know
branchial interdependence but they are i
believe nick may have a better a crisper
comment on this they are i believe they
are an optimization you do not need them
there are because what you're doing
there is using so like let's say you
want to constructively prove p and q
you'll want to get a proof of p and a
proof of q and you combine them to get a
proof of p n exactly right that's that's
what we call the cumulative evolution in
the mathematics piece
um
i mean you you um
but you don't need that you could do
well i don't know nick do you have a
last comment on this
i'm not sure
it's just it's not what we're doing when
we're searching for those proofs we're
we are proving qualities so it's not p
and q
right
yeah
so if it's being p and q equals to
something maybe p equals q i i really
need to go so um
all right good stuff good stuff um all
right to be continued okay see you guys
soon and by the way there's the at the
top of the hour is our discussion about
category theory which for people on the
live stream will also be live streamed
okay see you all soon